Sure.
Hi Dr Peterson over the last couple of
weeks and further back,
you talk a lot about consciousness and
the importance of it and I was hoping to
get your opinion on an issue of
consciousness that has often seen
Christianity among other groups and
politics kind of clash,
so I'm hoping to get your views on the
consciousness or lack thereof of a human
fetus and how that's impacted your views
on abortion,
whatever they are and any.
Cool.
Thank you.
Okay,
so the first question is do I have an
answer for that?
That's a good enough answer to actually
reveal.
No,
I don't,
but I'll.
I'll I can flail about a little bit
around it.
Abortion is clearly wrong.
Don't think anybody debates that you
wouldn't recommend that someone that you
love have one.
Okay.
Now,
having clarified that that mere
statement doesn't eliminate the
complexity of the situation.
The first question is,
is should everything wrong be illegal?
That's a tough question.
Everything that's wrong isn't illegal.
Then there's the additional complication
of the difference,
let's say,
in gravity regarding the problem in
relationship to men and women and we
don't know how to deal with that.
Having said that,
I would say that it's actually the wrong
question.
There's something Leonard Cohen said
once he said that in a massacre,
there's no decent place to stand,
and what he meant by that was sometimes
you're aware there is no good decision
left,
no matter what you do.
It's wrong.
So then the question is how did you get
there?
Well,
let's say you're in a position where you
are inclined to seek an abortion.
The question is,
how did you get there?
Now we have a lot to straighten out
about the sexual relationships between
men and women.
In the modern world,
they're bent and warped and demented out
of shape.
One of the things I see with young
people,
for example,
is that they will engage in sexual acts
with one another that they would not
talk about with one another.
I mean,
couples will do that for that matter,
like married couples will do that,
but they're married.
That's a different story.
It seems to me that if you are willing
to engage in a sexual act with someone
with whom you would not discuss that
act,
you probably put the cart before the
horse,
so the discussion regarding the legality
of abortion is nested inside a larger
discussion about the morality of
abortion and that's nested inside a
larger discussion about the proper place
of sexuality and human behavior and to
me that's the level at which the problem
needs to be addressed.
Now I don't have the answer to that.
You know,
because they will answer was get married
now.
It's a good answer and it's an answer
that people should still listen to,
but we'll put that aside momentarily.
I had a client at one point who was,
I don't know,
she was probably.
I'm not going to disguise her in a
variety of different ways.
She was 27,
20 or thereabouts,
had come from a relatively conservative
background,
quite a timid,
fearful person and also not very well,
not sophisticated in relationship to
relationships and she'd never had sex.
Well,
there's a bunch of things she'd never
done.
Well,
the answer from me to her wasn't
continued to be timid about everything
because that wasn't working out for her.
She needed to go have some adventures.
Now,
sexual adventures like other adventures
are dangerous and so you have to be very
careful when you encourage people to go
out and have adventures,
but,
but too much.
Timidity and caution also constitutes a
pathway to perdition.
Let's say you can't just say to people
in the morning world while you know,
sex till you're married,
unless you're going to get married when
you're very young and perhaps you
should.
I don't know about that,
but I don't think that we're mature
enough as a culture to have a serious
discussion about sexual impropriety,
especially in the aftermath of the birth
control pill.
And we seriously need to do that and we
have it.
And so I think the eternal debate about
abortion,
horrible as it is,
is a,
it's the surface manifestation of a much
deeper problem.
Now I talked a little bit today about
the utility of marriage,
like the spiritual utility of marriage,
and that's something that I think we're
so immaturely cynical as a culture like
we don't.
We're not wise enough to look at an
institution like marriage and to really
think about what it means and what it
signifies.
It signifies a place that people can tie
the ropes of their lives together so
that they're stronger.
It signifies a place where people can
tell the truth to one another.
It signifies a place where sexuality can
properly be integrated into life.
That's no easy.
That's no easy task.
It's a place where children,
at least in principle,
it can be put first and foremost as they
should be once they exist,
and so there's a much broader discussion
that has to happen.
I think before any concentration on the
legality of abortion is labeled to get
anywhere at all.
That's what it looks like to me,
so that's the best I can do with that
question.
Thank you.